all right good evening everybody welcome
to tonight's planning east committee my
name is Andy Crump
I will be chairing tonight's meeting
well we the planet merits of the
applications on the agenda please can
ask you to ensure your phones are
switched off or how can say that
gentleman at the back thank you put them
on silent or switched off because
there's nothing worse than being
interrupted for the sounds of the Great
Escape when you in full flow also could
ask members to enjoy towards me by not
interrupting the speakers however
irritating you might find them please
could you give them the courtesy of
speaking and only registered speakers
are there to speak thank you very much
sorry about that it sends a BitLocker
schoolmaster doesn't it but I think we
need to get the ground rules sorted out
it's a good I've had a good teacher
right thank you very much M what to
introduce the top table and on my right
we have I'm buying some committee
services make some legal services my
name is Richard Gardner
I'm the planning manager in my role is
an impartial advisor to the committee I
can clarify any planning issues that
arise doing so I'm bound by the code of
Professional Conduct the Royal Town
Planning Institute and planning
committee members not bound by the case
officers recommendation or by oral
advice Eddy wrench senior planning
officer Matthew Coyne planning officer
Ryan O'Keefe planning assistant Louise
Casey planning officer thank you non
chairmen very commendable full house
oh hey Thank You coach all right and
cravette disclosure of interest please
catch the sight thing against the Barnes
yes chairman the last item over three to
seven oh four jasmine cottage trail
eaten I am the applicants are just fair
and interesting and I should leave the
room right secondly I have had a letter
from Tetlow King and I expect we all
have of somewhere in Bristol concerning
the Elm Road carriages are stopped in
I've also had quite a missive here from
cirencester on about the north farm
cheering's in application so I've
received those in the post we catch the
brain any of that building catch the
barns any other disclosures yeah
rent thank you very much we'll let move
on to item three which is the
application number eighteen / 0 to 10
priests are taxes Thank You chair the
application is for a temporary
construction access onto the a 3400 the
application site is located at the
southern edge of new Bolden star and as
planning permission for 35 dwellings
this is an aerial view of the wider
development site with a permitted site
ax has been taken from the Burroughs to
the north and a current access to the
site being from Mill Lane to the south
this plan shows the proposed access
point of visibility splays this is a
zoom in of the same plan which shows a
cross-section of the access from
Stratford Road with the level changes
required to facilitate the development
this photo shows visibilities plays in
both directions from the proposed access
and finally this photo is from Mill Lane
looking towards the proposed access
across the development site chair there
are no updates to report and the
recommendation is to grant permission
subject to the conditions and notes
detailed on page 6 of the agenda thank
you speaker please which is catch the
site
Thank You chairman can I I was little
much surprised that you called me first
because of course the Parish Council had
put in an objection but they're not here
tonight and no I've been in touch with
the clerk when he does send their
apologies the reason being that the
meeting of the Parish Council would have
determined an attendee was sadly
cancelled at the last minute because of
a problem with the premises on Monday
evening secondly I am going to speak on
their behalf because they created a
situation I have objected and my details
are in there the question is that the
Parish Council have also objected
because what the case officer didn't
tell us in his presentation just then he
talked about visibility's plays which of
course are essential there because the
road is actually quite narrow and is
heavily hedged on both sides but the
point of the issue is there is a speed
limit through newbold OnStar and indeed
the proposed access would appear to be
just outside that speed limit and what
they have said the parish council in
their objection is that the speed limit
should be modified before any permission
is given to provide an access at this
point and I think that's quite a crucial
thing and it's quite outstanding risk of
being accused of treating an officer
with disrespect again in what I'm saying
but effectively I think that's quite a
serious omission that he didn't actually
refer to that in his presentation
because I think that's quite an
inhibiting factor the second thing is
that I would like to draw people's
attention to is what I have here the
Warwickshire Advisory Laurie route map
now this road the a3 400 is a major
route and under the latest revision to
the Advisory Laurie map which was
published last july by the county can
so the road here the a3 400 is included
as a major access route and I can tell
you now from my experience as the ward
member that I'm having considerable
amount of complaints from certain
quarters as to the volume of traffic
which we can do very little about
because it's not a district council
function before somebody tells me that
but but the situation is that we have a
serious problem where you've got a
fairly narrow ish main road built to
1970 standards when big lorries were
much smaller than they are now and we
have effectively a proposed Junction on
that narrow road where you're going to
have vehicles large vehicles moving in
and out of the site now the alternative
which was presented in the presentation
was accessed via the Burroughs the
Burroughs is in his State Road now I
also represent the residents of the
Burroughs and I've had lobbying from
them for saying can we please relieve
ourselves of access to this site from
the Burroughs that is correct and I'm
willing to support them in that I mean
that they should not be through a
housing estate be subject to huge huge
traffic congestion and a huge amount of
traffic movements
therefore what I'm saying is that
although a site is necessary the present
proposals have some very hugely limiting
factors because you're going to have a
an awkward Junction a new Junction which
is probably less than a hundred metres
from the next Road junction quite close
to it and therefore in planning terms I
think it's quite undesirable to have the
proposals as they are shown and there
has got to be a better solution one that
doesn't effectively cause congestion on
on a lorry route
and the primary access route and of
course we will know that the district
council didn't know too much about this
because I asked councillor Jefferson a
question at four council October about
this proposal of the new Lord there by
Zuri lorry route map and effectively he
said I didn't know anything about it
however I still await an answer from him
on this question of whether indeed the
maps been improperly approved but it is
published and it is agreed with the road
haulage Association and I know from my
erstwhile time as a County Council that
these things happen and I was involved
in earlier iterations of this map that
didn't include the a3 400 through new
board as part of a primary access route
so consequently I'm asking you on the
grounds of that dangerous an undesirable
Junction to reject these proposals
coupled with the parish councils view
that effectively the speed limit should
be repositioned very much cast aside
that was virtually spot-on oh I thought
I saw you boys I was sitting here
thinking am I gonna run out of time but
unfortunately I didn't know thank you
very much any questions for the order
number cancer Perry and then Kelly
O'Donnell
good evening chair and good evening
councillors st. obviously in the
committee report there is no objection
from highways what are your views in
this respect particularly there there
they're suggesting subject to conditions
and there is a condition already
recommended by the officers of no
unloading or loading either side of the
site but just be interested on your
views in the fact that
highways have issued no objection well
I'm afraid I treat highways as a
concerti not a dictator and I think they
seem to think that they can impose
situations on us which they're not
entitled to do I think we have to make a
judgement on planning terms the issue of
the
question of loading and unloading on the
main road would be dangerous because
traffic couldn't two-way traffic
couldn't get round any vehicles there so
I think that that is important but that
doesn't invalidate the plea that I'm
making to you that effectively
I can't secede um with regards to your
concerns on highways that's with regards
to potential danger do you have any
evidence or numbers on near misses or
accidents have happened on that stretch
of road if you're asking them to
consider changing a speed limit at the
moment no we don't have an accident
record that I'm aware of
maybe the simple reason is that the
people have come through the village and
effectively they're coming through the
village at 30 miles an hour and there is
another Junction at that point but what
I'm saying is that the the risk is
considerably greater if you're going to
have huge lorries entering and leaving
the size of this place on an
unrestricted section of road because the
temptation is and I can tell you from
experience I probably shouldn't confess
to this can you be to be brief please no
go I'll just give somebody what could
just just be briefly I done to your
point there I mean if mr. Nash insists
I'll just shut up completely because
that's the way he seems to behave
whenever I'm speaking no cancer saying
you carry on yeah I'm just seeking
further clarification as chair so if you
just want to briefly miss your point for
me please well now I think the point is
that there is no accident record of that
because of the speed limit but
effectively we're going to introduce a
new Junction close to another one in an
unrestricted section of that road and I
know what happens is because when you
drive along there you're tempted to
accelerate knowing that you're going
from a thirty mile an hour limit to a 60
mile an hour limit by this proposed
entrance thank you
all our entrance onto the site
it wants to stop putting temporary speed
limit signs up and even traffic lights
well perhaps I could but I think you
should ask the officers for that I would
expect some officer opinion on the
introduction I'm not saying you can't do
more counts though Fielding's suggested
I'm supporting the parish council in
their objections because of the position
of the present speed limit end thank you
yeah I've got some points that
Prophecy's their points for
clarification about speed limit
modification and outside the boundary so
yeah what tackle actually any further
questions for the warden
thank you can st. and could you switch
off the okay thank you right then
we've been swiftly on two points of
clarification catch the bonds
construction plan there is one as part
of the outline permission on site which
is being held in abeyance at the moment
because it will include basically which
access gets a pretty abduction it
briefly
speed limit modification and tell me
clarify is that side the boundary and
again the speed love if we did go for it
temporary change of the speed limit I
assume that would take a reasonable
amount of time as well in planning terms
County highways obviously assess it and
haven't requested any change in speed
limit at this point there is a permanent
speed limit change which was secured as
part the section 106 of the outline for
a TR o basically the funding of a change
in the speed limit but they haven't
requested anything on this short period
basically because of the
sympathy of Mill Lane and the situation
as it stands so in terms of attaching
conditions we wouldn't say it's
reasonable to a touch of condition that
hasn't been requested by highways other
points once we move on to debate to
catch the brain I think it's 50/50 at
that particular spot we dealt with this
in January last year and refused it when
it went to the inspector inspect and
overturned their decision and granted it
at that time it was for layout and scale
nothing about the road I know McCain to
counter right and so you but then I
listened to the County Council
and they have no objections in fact
there's five letters of support for the
application I see no reason to bummer I
wouldn't advise that we do that again
it's down to the communities made this
decision but we've had information from
the officer in the points of
clarification that highways have not
requested such a condition and we might
be in danger of putting on an
unreasonable condition so therefore I
would not support that any sorry kinds
of cuts the bonds in case of partner
battle with this site for some time now
and I posed if the Parish Council want
to continue but we haven't really got a
reason for refusal which will stand up
so I'm happy to second
that's the part counselor Barnes has
beaten me to it
I was happy to second the proposal there
is no planning reasons at all to go down
on the refusal route particularly on
highways because we have no objection
from highways yep so we've had a
proposal that we grant the application
as per the committee report and with the
conditions in the committee report
seconded by counts the Barnes all those
in favor
you know mr. chairman Thank You
committee resolved the grant application
1802 a 209 F few owl thank you
right just last year few seconds to get
ready when they move on to our next item
which is 18 / 0 3 1 5 6 fu our North
farm north on Road Cherrington no state
running and double PF / 79 proposal and
poor house with garden landscape and
ecology enhancement proposals result
revised submission of 18 / 0 107 if you
are presenting officer thank you
unfortunately I've been advised that
when we started the process now and you
will have to come back later date either
in person or even write an oli mileage
and question in the process that we went
through during the application so 140mm
and although to give you access today
I'm afraid sorry that happy 9p sir yeah
I think we'll obviously I didn't realize
you're sorry I didn't realize you that
you were speaking anyway so if you want
to raise that point to on the your time
lighter in the process as part of this
application I will lay you a little bit
extra time for you to make that point
and then it will be noted it's part of
the minutes rather than debate it now
when you come up we will ask you the
question and then and then we'll decide
on it so we'll time to give you a
reasonably vegetal but I don't want to
have insisted right now before we
actually started the agenda item Thank
You chairman so the application site
relates to north farm which is northwest
of Cherrington southwest of brailles
with brows hill just on the east side of
the the back dot there and the
application so it's also east of
Willington and chips anon style just in
the top left of the screen there there's
a public highway up to the application
site
center of the map from from there up to
the back dog there's a public highway
and then it's public private away from
the black dog to the north so this is
the application of citation in red the
existing site contains a number of
agricultural buildings an existing
farmhouse there's also an existing
agricultural building outside of the
application site to the to the west
there's a number of mitigation measures
ecological mitigation measures in that
barn outside of the application site
which was approved under the the extant
Planning Commission which was approved
in 2012 the sites in the Cotswolds a OMB
with the western side of the site being
the boundary of the Cotswolds amb and
then beyond that is the Cotswolds fringe
special landscape area so this is a
scenario view of this site as you can
see the the farmhouse the existing
farmhouse on the site is just where the
the cursor is on the screen at that
moment and then you can see the number
of other agricultural buildings across
the site the track leading up to the
site from the south again is public
highway up set up to the site and then
it's probably prior to way beyond browse
Hills just on the right-hand side so the
application seeks permission to demolish
the existing buildings on the site and
erect a replacement dwelling the main
the main dwelling itself was comprised
of a 2-story dwelling with basement
there's also a cloister arrangement to
the to the west which has got a gym an
office and two ancillary accommodation
units in there this is just a sort of an
artistic impression of the the proposal
looking towards the northwest and again
this is just an artist expression
looking from the access tract up towards
brailles Hill in terms of this drawing
there there is landscaping proposed and
on the front of that site
the view of the property would be
slightly obscured by that but us just to
give you a sort of view of the process
this planner shows the the proposed
layout of the dwelling so the main part
of the dwelling is on the right-hand
side there with the cloister arrangement
on the left and the ancillary
accommodation the gyms down here and the
estate office is in this location
first of all planned to showing the main
dwelling and then the first floor
elements in the cloister part these are
the north and south elevations of the
dwelling and again this is looking from
east to west to east I believe and then
they plan at elevations of the pool
house which is sitted situated to the
north of the site this is a comparison
plan but which shows the 2012 permission
which is on the right-hand side of the
of the screen there and then the the
left-hand side shows the the footprint
of what's now being proposed again a
comparison plan in terms of elevations
the the blue or purple lines on there to
show the existing farmhouse with the
sort of single-story agricultural
buildings just extending to the left the
red shows the extant planning permission
from 2012 and then this shows the art
overlaid over the top of the proposed
elevations so in terms of photographs
this is looking from the access track
north towards the bride away
so the Nissen hats on the left hand side
and the application side is on the right
hand side and then this is looking from
the bride away back towards the access
track so the sites on the left hand side
there this is a view looking towards
brailles Hill so you can see across the
site as a number of agricultural
buildings the farmhouse is just situated
behind that wall and then again this is
looking
Northwest towards the existing farmhouse
you can see the existing farmhouses sort
of tradition its architecture its brick
ville with a slate roof and then this is
another view of looking at across the
site with the agricultural buildings in
there and then this is just looking from
the boundary of the site up towards
brailles hills so you can just notice
it's quite quite open sight there as a
couple of updates on the update sheet so
there's there's some additional comments
received after the report was written so
they're there in there there was also
some legal advice receives on how we
dealt with the previous application and
say that that's for a thirteen year
update sheet there was also a TAC review
peer review of the scheme and then a
brief summary of that's included in the
update sheet as well so members are
recommended to refuse the application
for the reasons that are on page 26 if
your agenda thank you much Thank You
Matthew after one or two starts they
finally got there we move on to our
first speaker which is pence the Philip
Townsend from Cherrington Parish Council
he didn't realize it with an obstacle
course as well did he didn't realize it
was gonna be an obstacle course to get
here is a right and you've got three
minutes on he said thirty minutes then
and that's not very agent are those also
and would you like a warning with about
ten seconds to go or are you okay
and could you put the machine on spits
right Rob firstly we wish to come in the
committee to be aware the parish council
only received notification in this meet
on the 11th of January this lighter
nerve detachment totally unacceptable
secondly Terence Norton parity do not
object to the proposed new dwelling
however Dylan however it adamantly
objects that permission being granted
until the issue of public and vehicle
access has been resolved what the
Planning Committee is being asked to do
endorses the illegal removal removal of
a public vehicle turning area and
restrict the width of an existing
vehicle right of why the documents
supporting this application failed to
clarify the road through the development
site is an adopted Road maintained at
public expense the planning application
states the no changes to the existing
public rights-of-way this is incorrect
the planning application shows fencing
and hedge planting on public areas that
prevent access to the vehicle turning
area and restricts the width of the road
such that vehicles can no longer pass
safely past pedestrians horse riders or
cyclists the committee should also be
aware that in the past the turning area
was maintained by the council whenever
the road was resurfaced in
correspondence seen by the parish
council and the applicant has refuted
that it is a public road and also the
existence of the vehicle turning area
the planks in front of you have removed
the existing turning area I repeat the
application that you are being asked to
approve either restricts or removes
public rights-of-way
access over the historic old riff road
set out in the status of 1805 we
understand it is a requirement for an
adopted know through Road to have a
vehicle turning area where it terminates
the plant being submitted have removed
the vehicle turning area and hence do
not comply with highway regulations the
Parish Council understands John Glenn
demon from Warwickshire highways has not
visited the site and his approval of the
application is based on the assumption
that there is no restriction to the
vehicle er rights of access this is
clearly not the case
Jones Staunton Parish Council also want
to know if the vendor is willing to pay
money towards the maintenance of the
road due to the large number of lorries
that have gone up there carrying stone
to make another Road because it is 30
seconds to conclude that gentleness
Norfolk Council wish to ensure before
planning permission is granted the
applicant acknowledges in writing first
the public vehicle right-of-way
secondly the vehicle turning area the
existing farm buildings will be
reinstated thirdly confirms the width of
the public right-of-way setting statue
since 1805 finally repeat the planning
application states no changes to public
rights of access this is clearly not the
case and if the committee approves the
application in its current format will
be endorsing an illegal removal of
public vehicle turning area thank you
very much that's just fair spot on any
questions
if you go back to one of the pictures
that shows whoa and gone past it
wherever a vehicle is parked on one not
one boy than listen hot then one the
other side fire and that one there yeah
that is where that turning circle was
because up where that gate is there
because that gate was unlocked a gate
which was obstructing the public high a
public highway and it has now since been
moved to the other side by the other
other end of that missing heart so it
was a locked gate so you couldn't get up
there but it it is a public road and the
sign at the end of the road is you're
coming in from Charenton said a no
through road not a no access road
but I noticed notice when you were
showing it before only that one where
than listen what was on it's not on
there see it's all been that is where is
landscape and it see he is doing away
with that turning area
okay so fed I think we might and will
get slightly confused here thank you for
those points the point about the Gantt
is particularly pertinent know through
so again that's more in valuable
information we will raise the point of
clarification where the offices when
they come that part of the agenda okay
so the Perry you indicated Thank You
councillor Townsend good evening you
mentioned in your presentation that the
parish council has no objection to the
actual proposals of the building to the
actual building the built form I just
wonder whether I can ask you you're the
parish council views as to whether you
feel the proposals would in would
significantly enhance the immediate
setting and whether they are sensitive
to the characteristics of the area in in
the proposals that have been brought
forward well it's it's like a lot of
things it's it'll look strange to start
with but in another 15 20 years time
folks will think wow that's a nice
building so you know it's just it's the
same as everything you won't watch
episodes I hasten it's going to look bad
for for a few weeks and then after after
a while everybody else I not all right
then
so in in in your view speaking on behalf
the Parish Council there is there was no
conflict in terms of its immediate
setting and the characteristics of the
area no that's the bonds you think you
I'm just clarifying you said you had
information on the 11 is that correct
was that to do with the turning circle
that you don't know I know
the letter that we had tell us about
this meeting tonight our dude it was
dates that it was printed on the night
and we received it on the 11th which was
Saturday so you try and work something
out between Saturday and yeah again
we'll try and find out what's wrong yeah
concern it was one of the neighboring
parishes that told us about it last week
but we have received we have not
received anything until now so get in
points of clarification to see what can
be learned about this as well so yeah
thank you for raising that with us
cancer brain solid labor the fine
did you not have a consultation and
debated at parish council yeah we did we
sell this player application last
November time you had noticed but you
didn't have notice of the meeting we
didn't notice at this meeting
no yeah we've had consultation yes we've
seen both sets of plans that the
original plan the revised plan we saw
the plan from the 2012 Thank You Senor
you're free to go
our next speaker mr. Martin me and Craig
Hamilton say if we would come to when
the tables either one the suitable
gentlemen if we could briefly tell us
your point of clarification objection
before you start your three minutes I'll
give you a reasonable amount of time but
I think y'all live in the point or going
on too long I will cut you off so thank
you for that and I had no wish to hijack
the meeting the fact is that the two
reports that are only reported on today
with the supplementary officers
additional words were submitted in
November and December they were not
referenced in the officers report to
committee and they were not put on the
planning portal despite our request
until I think it was the 10th of this
month now the officer said despite those
major reports they would not change his
mind which had already been made up to
recommend refusal we have not had the
opportunity to respond to his review
even though it's only a single sheet and
on behalf of my client had his comments
been in the officers report we could
have raised those issues
because we feel it's it would be flawed
for a committee refusal to be based on
dismissal of those reports which were
duly submitted in November and December
but which were not taken into
consideration or at least not reported
on within the offices report and
obviously I'm here to make sure that my
clients interests are properly
represented and protected not to
criticize the officer we just want the
Fair Play and I ask the question have
members all had the opportunity to read
and review those reports and to take
them into account in their pre committee
deliberations
that's all I wish to say you will
discuss that after your the water member
we've got some points of clarification
where we will Richard we've got some
made a note of those points and we'll be
responding accordingly but by doing it
this way your your comments have been
noted it's part of the minutes as well
so we can move on just ask mr. Lee when
you speak do you want to give us a nod
or something so we can move the slides
on as you go so thank you I've spoken
with the officer and we are going to
refer to the sheets that are in the
presentation summary that were submitted
with the application they are letter
referenced a 1 to 6 and B to F and at
each time we will start our next
sentence with sheet a3 for instance and
that's the time to advance in places we
are taking three sheets together so we
would ask that if we say sheets 4 5 6
that you just put them up in turn very
briefly but thank you sir thank you for
agreeing that we could use this document
before we go on I just want to raise a
point with the committee so I'm sorry to
stop you on this occasion and it's all
to do with natural justice I'm sure your
finger begins here this one obviously
that the agent has raised the issue that
the members might not have seen all the
information in detail
it's been submitted so therefore there's
the argument that we could be making a
decision without all the information
that is available okay we've had a
summary from the officer and I've got no
problems with the summary but just
committee want to potentially defer
before we go any much further so we can
actually receive all the information and
read it properly the documents referred
to have been available on the website
for the same period that members would
have had time to read the committee
report so in reading the committee
reports they could have made reference
to those on the website if they so wish
so don't believe anyone's been
prejudiced
that's the band's you okay oh we're just
going to say they don't think that is a
reasonable way forward for everybody
because I appreciate they'll have to
come again but it does look as though
there's been in my eyes not
maladministration but he could have been
done better and I'm quite happy to
propose a payroll if you feel that's
appropriate well I do I'm just having
issues about whether this is the
appropriate forum chair
Richard is advised that you know there's
no prejudice towards the applicants all
the members I just believe that if there
are issues about procedure then that is
something that the council should look
at after the application I mean
sometimes you fall but this is probably
not the appropriate time to actually
assess those types of matters I would
advise the applicants basically to write
in ASAP so the council can assess
whether we have actually undertaken the
correct procedure according to the
polymer agent we haven't so I'm quite
happy to go with what Richard has said
so cancer brain cancer scientist
efficient time to look at the file with
a comprehensive stuff come through the
mail which we've had chance to read or
not read I think I'm gonna turn back to
the applicant and ask him if he's are
happy for this hearing to go ahead I
tempted to say if you're minded to grant
consent let's please carry on
clearly we're all here I think we should
go ahead I think if you reminded sir we
have got a set presentation which will
take two minutes 58 seconds if you were
willing to grant me another three
minutes I would have my say about the
significance of those documents because
if the officer's mind was made up
without having taken them into account
his report cannot be comprehensive now
fortunately so if I may finish you've
gone briefly fortunately we were able to
provide all members with electronic and
hardcopy summary of the whole scheme so
I think the members have full
information about the scheme but I don't
think they have full information about
the peer review and legal review the
site Lancaster brain yes chairman I'm
not enthusiastic about deferring this
application we've had the stuff in the
post which I've had a look at thoroughly
and also the supplementary information
which we've had tonight on arrival
refers to legal advice relating to the
previous planning application now then
that may well be background information
but we're looking at the current
planning application and I feel
particularly well advised on the nature
of that application and the contents and
unless someone's going to raise
something that makes me doubt whether I
have got enough information in order
make a decision I will be quite happy to
proceed Thank You councillor Saint
that's very helpful the brain I'm going
to refer to the parish council to start
with the parish councils had only had a
few days to make a decision but if you
look at the report the parish council
wrote into the council on the fifth of
the 1218 with their objections which are
clearly on page 13 so they did have time
to turn into the Agean he clearly isn't
satisfied with the procedure that were
carrying coming out and then minded to
ask for a deferral so everybody is happy
in this process I would second that
because I think it's necessary we're
getting ourselves soldiers to come in
mr. chairman apologies sorry but I think
we are getting ourselves tied up in Knox
and given where we are now I think
you'll be safer first just to defer may
to everyone's happy and then come back
to this fresh because I fear that we are
getting a bit confused about what's been
given in so just for the sake of clarity
second counts the brains proposal 510
those against two sections one committee
results to affirm the application thank
you next up on the agenda
that was interesting but move on to the
next item which is 18 / 0 2 3 1 2 / fu
bow three ways Christ Northend proposed
first full extension over the garage in
kitchen and extension to the rear and
our case off that's easier on O'Keeffe
so welcome Ron thank you very much thank
you Jalen the site is located in the
small village of North End which lies
within the parish of Burton Bassett and
within the special landscape area of
Einsteins Hill fringe number freelee's
close if one of four brick-built
detached two-story properties located in
a small culver act on the edge of the
village of a north end there is a sharp
level change from the main road to the
top of the cul-de-sac and as a result
each property is a slightly different
level to each other so this is a site
plan of the close and the property is in
the left-hand corner at the top of the
plan there is a double width Drive to
the front of the property with the main
amenity space to the side and the rear
so the dwelling is predominately
two-story with a small single store
elements to the right-hand side of the
property which are contacts both of the
kitchen and the double garage which sits
slightly forward of the principal
elevation of the house so moving on to
the proposals so Planning Commission is
sought to construct a first floor
extension over the garage and a
two-story extension at the rear to
provide further bedroom accommodation
our first floor which is accessed by
separate internal staircase a new
extension will project of the rear of
the property
which is slightly visible on the bottom
left-hand side with the two windows and
a two-story extension to the rear
that's like politics but and then a
further extension will be built over the
existing garage adjacent but won't
extend over the second garage so part of
the roof of the garage will remain which
is shown here the garage is below the
extension will remain in the city and
during the course of the application the
proposal have been amended several times
to reduce the overall impact to the
neighbors
mostly number to leave closed which is
where the pointer is at the moment the
key issues are the impact on neighbors
more number two lee's close again
highlighted here and the parking issues
both raised his objections for the
parish council so this shows the roof
plan which shows a 45-degree breach of
the existing garage from the closest
abital window of the neighbor which is
number two leaves closed so as I
mentioned number two of these codes is
located to the northwest of the
application site and see it's lower than
the application property approximately
2.2 meters the outlook for Miss neighbor
is currently poor given there is a large
retaining wall and the garage of the
applicant I'd mentioned the existing
garage early breaches the 45 min 25 and
from the closest window but there is a
secondary window to that living room of
the neighbor and the proposals that
first floor are 3.8 meters away from
this win
so there won't be any further impact
than what already exists between these
neighbors in terms overshadowing an
overbearing and also you mentioned
earlier there are two windows to the
side elevation which will face directly
to the neighbor which will be obscura
glazed over condition to prevent any
overlooking ground floor plan or C's
showing the issues raised by the
perishable parking so you can clearly
see Larry's two parking spaces available
from the front driveway here and one
parking space remaining in full use with
no internal work compromising the
internal layout of that garage the draft
parking standards provides guidance
which require that a property with four
or more bedrooms to a minimum of free
parking spaces which you can clearly see
has been accommodated within the
proposals so I'm satisfied that the park
the parking and has been addressed
within the application some gifs and
photos just to give you some reference
so this is the approach to the
cul-de-sac the village of no offense
enough towards the front of the photo
and the approach on the right-hand side
this is obviously looking up towards the
application site and you can clearly see
the level changes and as you get in you
can also see the level changes between
the neighbors this is at the front of
the property so you can see obviously
the double garage and the two parking
spaces at the front and then again this
is looking towards the neighbor number
two and you can see the level changes
between the two neighbors this is taken
from the neighbors garden so you can see
the retaining wall the garage and the
level change is quite apparent and that
is looking further back from the
neighbor back towards the property
pretty comprehensive that that clever
first speaker please which is catch the
Gordon coming from Burt and aerospace
Council committee an insert how are you
sure you know they just go by now been
here a few times
would you like a warning with 30 seconds
to go I don't think it'll go that far I
have one page thank you very much far
away Oh have you got my presentation up
doesn't do much more than your photos
but
okay lace clothes is a densely
constructed group of four large detached
dwellings and a single older bungalow
the newer properties already present a
density that is out of keeping with the
surrounding village one mitigation to
this over development was the mix of
single-story and two-story parts of the
property in question this application
would remove that mix creating a huge
property filling the skyline from a
viewpoint on lays closed and the
existing bungalow neighboring properties
have expressed their concerns at the
likely overbearing nature of the
finished property and I would ask the
planning officer to pay a little more
attention to this then the planning
officer dealing with the willows
development on top Street did to our
concerns over density and irreparable
damage to the street view our second
concern is over the parking arrangements
as you can see in the first photo there
is no parking available unless closed
itself on bottom Street at the next
slide yeah to the left heading out of
the village is a series of tight bends
meaning parking is not possible for some
200 yards in this direction being too
close to the bend and creating a severe
risk to other road users since there's
no visibility and as you can see there
are two cars parked in the entrance to a
farmer's field when I took this photo
parking is already an issue in this part
of the village and the next slide is to
the right is the red line in with car
parking and drop curbs all the way to
the pear trees junction meaning safe
parking that does not present an issue
to customers of the pub entering and
exiting the carpark is not available
until beyond pear trees some 100 plus
yards away from the property in
Stratford rostov element of requirements
document which he just mentioned and I
discovered today he state that in order
for a single carriage to be treated as
such the door must be at least 2.4
meters wide and the door on the existing
single garage to be retained is only two
point one meters wide this is not and
will not be used to park a car meaning
this proposal does not have the required
parking provision having just two spaces
according to Stratford districts rules
this therefore is in breach of your own
requirements and must therefore be
declined allowing a six bedroom house
and I'll point out this simplistic three
plus having three parking spaces 30
seconds it's somewhat simplistic and
this house is going from four bedroom
two six and there's obviously no
requirement have any further parking
spaces allowing a six bedroom house to
only have two parking spaces ignores
your own rules and create significant
risk to the traffic and residents and I
also committee to align with the parish
council on this matter and reject this
application thank you any questions for
the just confirm that bit about the
garage you saying it's a two point one
compared to the standard of two point
four four so that the double garage has
two single garages and they're both the
doorway is 2.1 meters according to the
plans that they've submitted and I
notice your requirement is two point so
I mean yeah I sort of then quickly look
like a Jaguar XF which i think is fairly
common in the village you would have a
two inch clearance each side in order to
drive it through said drive the doorway
so I don't mean it will there will be
two and as soon as you got the first
child having a car in this house and
they will be parking it somewhere on the
street on bottom string causing
obstruction thank you very much any
further questions thank you sir you're
now free to go right not working and
then we move on to our ward member
cancer kettle chairman and the council
to give our Chairman is full title Thank
You castle we've got five minutes
mr. chairman I completely concur with
what counsel Gordon coming have just
said this is a tightly designed closed
when it was first put together and they
are very attractive but there are quite
close together and what we're saying
here is in terms of some visual impact a
significant increase of the volume of
the highest property the impact there
was already a 45 degree impact from the
existing property on its neighbor and
whilst the extension will not enhance
that because it has been designed not to
the overall impression will be the the
bulk the volume of this property which
does given the topography of the site
very much over there the lower property
I have made a concerns with that I hope
I've made myself clear on that point
and then we get on to parking we see in
every single settlement where we've had
significant developments going forward
that every spare space is being used for
friends relations children and
grandparents whoever else may be living
improperly so much very much smaller
absolutely mr. Nostrand the in this case
we are building a substantial property
and we just looked at previous although
you didn't determine it they proved this
very substantial property where there is
ample room for parking and here we have
completely the opposite we have a very
narrow approach road the lays there is
not ample room to park or surplus room
to park additional properties what would
happen I know you can't cancel this but
if the worst of the developments are
things that we can't consider it now I
know you've got very point in you
telling us I'm just floating the idea
but this is because
to clay where are these extra bedrooms
and the problem and the cars they're
going to generate where are they gained
park is this could design we are
required now called strategy to consider
good design and actually designing or
allowing a design which has no spare
capacity for additional parking gives me
a real problem notwithstanding the
comments mr. Gordon Cummings made about
the access of the adequacy of the
original garages anyway but it does have
an impact on where those cars get to
park so if they don't park in the lays
you've seen the road from North End go
down to the B for 100 we've seen in the
picture two vehicles currently using a
farmer's gateway and regrettably what we
do know is that this route
inappropriately is used as a cut through
by lorries from the Southam Banbury Road
to the Warwick Bambury Road and there's
a history of vehicles came through this
village we cannot have surplus cars
unable to be accommodated on the Lai's
or within the site parked on this very
narrow country lane so where are they
going to go the issue is I don't know it
again to try and park in the cup car pub
car park which is private property
either get a park elsewhere in the
village is that remotely desirable
so what talking about here is good
design and frankly remembers the
committee we have a problem here in that
whilst it may not technically breach the
45 degree limit in terms of light the
design is not helpful to the other
properties and their living conditions
combine that with where on earth of the
cars going to go what we'll end up with
is having a logjam and that is not good
design so I think I'll rest my case at
that point I endorse everything
counselor Gordon coming said and I'm
resting within your good house
councillor box I'll ask a question first
night
catch the balance I believe indicated I
was just kidding except this is in a
cul-de-sac with a number of houses it's
the end house what you speak on police
microphone hidden the middle one I know
it's the top end so it's the highest
property in the block of four
effectively so you got one two three
four and it's number three top end so
it's farthest from the access road oh no
Council kettle um
are you suggesting that the extension is
not subservient to the original building
from what you're saying with the guards
to design and impact and therefore not
in keeping with cs20 I have problems
with what defining what is subservient
is not I'm sorry counselor Donal as mad
as I think in this case it my concern is
there is a rhodium an impact on the
neighboring property which as we've
identified in breach of the 45 degree
line I'm what you're doing is in not
technically in harnessing that but the
adjust the overall bulk will make a
significant difference to the setting of
the property is distracted any further
questions for the ward member Thank You
mr. chairman you're free to go points of
clarification no for the officers please
okay it's the brain
has been talking or there was attentive
to what he was saying what I want to
know I mean the parish council said that
would only be a minimal distance each
side of the garage door I thought it
said the calculation is 2 and 1/2 inches
even so what I want to know is is the
garage the same with us a door yeah
you've heard on the important point that
councilor brain which is whilst the the
width there is two point one and you
wouldn't be able to open a car door at
that point importantly it's the
requisite width once you're at the point
where you've parked the car and you need
to open the door so it does comply with
the standards at that point it's 2.4
meters
no it's not it's not ideal but it does
meet the standard just 2.4 I think it
was yeah I think the standard is 2.4
obviously these in draft at the moment
so we can only give them I think I think
the first council chairman actually
mentioned 2.4 as well and his
presentation is being in the guidance of
our catch the Gordon coming did you when
we've come forward so we couldn't hear
you on that which I come forward just to
clarify your points just so we're
Richard is writing as well just know
Club yeah the doorway is 2.1 and this is
I'm focusing on the doorway not the not
the size of the inside of the garage
because your draft report talks about
the doorway not the interior of the
garage and it has to be 2.4 wide and
it's 2.1 the inside is difficult to say
because you've got a sort of a twin
garage there which obviously they won't
be using one side of it but you can see
from that drawing the the added width
once you get past the door jamb is is
minimal and I don't suppose it's two
point four two cars worth no the rules
are on the doorway not the inside of the
garage it should be two point for the
doorway yes yes
thank you very much thank you coming
back
I think I'm probably going to need five
minutes to dig out the relevant guidance
because it appears that whilst we've got
parking SPD coming forward I've got a
copy of that here this further SPD which
I'll need to check in terms of parking
sizes which doesn't appear to be in the
first draft that I've got here so I'm
gonna just have to do a bit of digging
I'm happy to propose an adjournment for
five minutes is anybody
okay well we'll adjourn for five minutes
thank you
McCleary I'm Richard we've got the point
of clarification about the garage in the
garden such as sir could you follow I
please
okay thank you for the adjournment mr.
chairman that was useful it's a the
parking is actually in two different
parts of the SPD I was looking at part F
there's also Part D which deals with the
actual sizes of parking spaces and the
Parish Council are quite right that the
size of parking spaces and the access to
them there's a stipulation in the
guidance that the width of it should be
2.4 meters wide at the point of access
where the garage door is this is
actually two point one meters so it it
wouldn't make that part of the guidance
what I would say is that in theory would
leave only two spaces for the proposed
dwelling but it should also be borne in
mind that this has been built as it
stands now I can't say whether or not it
has actually been used as a garage but
nonetheless it has been built as a
double garage albeit a thinner one than
the SPD would suggest is acceptable my
own planning view on this is that the
guidance is in draft format it's got
therefore got limited weight and that
this would provide two parking spaces
for the bed for the for the property and
therefore given the limited weight that
that would that would remain acceptable
and therefore the recommendation stands
from officers however members will wish
to take into account that it there is
according to the guidance if you apply
it rigidly there are only two spaces
available thank you that's clear mr.
Perry yes can I just have offices kara
fication the report mentions of the four
properties in this particular closed are
all the properties are similar size in
in the first instance all the other
properties in there the same as this
property is before the big extension
predominant certifies you've
predominately they are the same size
some have been altered with extensions
to them but they predominantly remain
that's four-bedroom dwellings the
principle of application and while the
application is being submitted is it's
an application for two families coming
together to live under one roof now it's
why it is now a six bedroom dwelling
right any further questions
okay so just in time
um can I return to the question I asked
the ward member about whether the
extension was considered subservience to
the original building that's a very good
question thank you you're going to move
it to the elevations just to reiterate
my points I'm going to make
so this application has been amended
several times when the application came
in for the first time were going
considerably all the way to the end of
the garage and building the built form
from predominantly single-story to the
two-story all the way up to that end
bridge that was amended to a hipped roof
towards and away from the neighbor which
again the parish and that is why we're
here today with thank you chairman I'm
following in the footsteps of councilor
brain my my main concerns is I feel this
is actually over development to the site
and it's out of character with the other
dwellings in this particular closed its
I wouldn't have had so much a problem
with the parking with the garage if the
road leading up to this particular
property had provision for parking if we
would if we were looking at this as a
standalone
in a much larger estate
it the the issues around parking
wouldn't wouldn't apply but at the end
of the day someone with a six a six
bedroom property even if they have a
children's birthday party
no one can park and it's sort of 200
yards away so I feel I can't support
this application I think the parish
council made a very professional
presentation identifying serious reasons
within this very small small close but I
also feel that the proposals represent a
built form that is out of character with
the rest of the properties neighboring
properties it's over development to the
site and overbearing in view of the
nature of the close and because of the
narrowness of the roads there's no
additional parking availability on the
road the parking provision is
insufficient and on those grounds I have
to refuse this application terms the
bonds to social media which we don't
know about but the size bulk and mass of
the extension is I think too great
they're not all be going to be ride in
push bike so the garage will be big
enough there'll be you know coming in
there Motor Vehicles so I agree with the
last speaker really unfortunately there
has been amendments to it I have tried
to get it right that her officer feels
they say okay but I'm not so sure
Krista site sir it's chair and I'd like
to chip in on the parking standards
issues what people have said is broadly
in line with my thoughts but the
situation is it's all very well
officers to say a second please
somebody's phone I'm not sure whether
whose friend that was but it might have
been mine
I've actually been heckled by your own
fans oh that's okay to say so before you
go with slightly mischievous chairman
that was yeah but seriously it's all
very well for officers to say it is in
draft form therefore it has limited
weight I accept that point that's
correct but what was approved cabinet
the other day was a revision to what was
approved twelve months ago when cabinet
also put an issue forward on parking
standards and effectively a lot of these
issues have already been subject to a
consultation and I've got to go through
another one so I'm not convinced that
they're going to be challenged so I
think we can give perhaps a little bit
more weight that might be suggested to
the to those parking issues Thank You
chair really is following on from
councilor brain that it is a shame
happening it's not here there could be
very specific reasons they need the six
bedrooms with regards to parking it's
it's not just about these this family
living here if they go on to sell the
parking issues will continue won't they
and the fact it's in draft form with
regards to the parking regulations they
will at some point become concrete so I
think adopted that's what I was looking
for thank you so following on from
counts the brain and councillor Perry I
will be looking not to follow the
officers recommendation honest I thought
there was almost upon there you can say
it set in stone or something like that
so catch the brain
I think there's other items mentioned as
well in camps Aparri mentioned it was
overbearing out of character I think
it's the Barnes mentioned sighs Balkan
mus any second just just clarified
clothes good so just to clarify the
reasons I put the first reason has been
over development of the site out of
keeping with other properties on the
clothes and that's exacerbated by the
fact it's next to opened countryside the
second reason I might just need a bit of
clarification on not appreciated members
if I understood it correctly that it's
the fact that the garage the entrance
the neck of the garages is below what
the SPD says that's persuaded members
that would be inadequate parking on site
and that would exacerbate parking issues
in the area I'm a rough go be careful
what I say but I'm taking it that if the
if that wasn't the case and that third
parking space is available that members
would be happy yeah no no is an unfair
question so as it stands the SPD
effectively says this has got two
parking spaces for a six bed darling and
that's unacceptable and the extension
would exacerbate the existing parking
under provision German can I just chip
in here I also sent the cumulative
impact of all these planning reasons
also has an impact on neighboring
amenity I'd be concerned about other
than that because it meets the 45 degree
test and that's our test for neighbor
immunity so okay we've you willing to
second that go safari so propose own
seconder to refuse this application for
the reasons that Richard is noted do you
want when they're finally drafted you
want them running past huge are you
happy for that to be delegated to
officers happy flat delegated offices so
all those in favor of catch that brains
proposal to refuse us application please
indicate you know miss chairman
committee it resolves to refuse
application 1802 three one two ful to
our next item
which is 18 / 0 3 1 0 4 ful garages
around Stockton Thank You chairman
so the the application site relates to a
garage block development and to the
north of Stockton as indicated by the
black dot on your screen there there are
a number of constraints the site they'll
come on to in a moment but that includes
a public right-of-way that leaves the
site in the north and this all goes
across the fields in that direction so
in terms of cyclists race at the moment
the site's occupied by 24 garages ten of
which are currently occupied there's a
public right-of-way which leaves the
site in the northwest corner here and
goes across the fields there's a public
well is that there's a footpath that
leads through the houses to the in front
of the Georgia Street houses here
there's an act an existing access that
leads to the rear garden of 72 George
Street in this location here so there's
a substation in this corner of the site
and there are a number of changes in the
level so it slopes down hill to the
right-hand side there's also changes in
levels between the site and the land to
the rear and again I think there's some
changes between the site itself and the
gardens of the property is adjacent
there's there's new listed buildings in
the sign it's not in a conservation area
so the proposal is to demolish the the
garages on the site and direct3d
dwellings in the terrace
the gardens are south-facing and to the
rear and then they front onto an access
road each dwelling is two bedrooms and
it's served by two allocated car parking
spaces again as the access to the rear
of 72 George Street remains and then
there's at
headin in here as well so just run
through the floor plans and elevations
again they're the sort of modest to to
bed dwellings relatively simplistic
construction red brick under a gray tile
roof
that's the elevation you can see that
there's a change in level across the
site I'm going down hill to the left has
just run through some photos so that's
the access to the site it's it's
predominantly single track there is sort
of occasionally space to get two
vehicles down there but it's
predominately single track as a footpath
on the right-hand side and then the
footpath of the leaves the site is
directly in the middle of the screen
there it goes uphill out of the site
there so this is looking down head
across the site say the produc the
majority of the guard is on the left
hand side there is a smaller the garages
on the right hand side as well you can
just see the fencing for the substation
on the right-hand side of the screen
there as well this is looking from the
footpath back towards the rear
elevations of some of the properties on
jory you can sort of get a feel for the
change in the levels between the
footpath and the sort of the roof of the
garage is there that just shows the the
rear access 272 George through the path
that goes around to the front of the
properties is just the other side of
that pillar there this is looking from
the public right-of-way back towards the
site there's quite a lot of scrub in
front of the garages there you sort of
get an idea of again the changes in
level and then that's looking back
uphill towards the access to the to the
time so the application is in your
agenda sign on page 37 members are
recommended to approve the application
subject to the condition set on page 47
the final wording it's recommended to
delegate to officers thank you first
speakers from Stockton which is catch
the Collison and mr. Robinson just
I'll give you such a head three minutes
is usual how'd you know the do you need
a warning probably not but it wouldn't
hurt okay first of all can I just clear
up a possible misunderstanding we become
recently aware of a question about the
Clarkes failure to declare personal
interest in this case he actually
occupies one of the garages but as
you'll be aware the parish councilors
make decisions over their position on
any planning application and the clerk's
job is to execute that role and
obviously his name will be on any
documentation but he plays no part in
the decision-making process and his
chairman I'm quite satisfied that we
followed a proper procedure in this case
dealing with the case itself
Stockton Parish Council has always
supported the principle of the provision
of additional affordable housing as we
do in this case however on this
application there are concerns about
problems that could arise during
construction and that might have
long-term effects to the northwest of
the access road and that we should we
saw the photograph earlier there's a
steep Bank down from the field above and
during sustained wet periods there has
always been significant flooding through
the garage area any damage which is
caused to this fragile Bank on the north
on the left-hand side of the action
access path during construction could
destabilize the bank
especially if any of the hedges or trees
there are damaged by large construction
vehicles or plant the parish council
would ask therefore that a retaining
wall is built to support this bank as
the first stage of any construction
process secondly the number of garages
currently used for parking is not clear
and neither is the future provision for
that
parking orbit have stated that they
there will be no increase in on street
parking but until they can guarantee
that all cars displaced will be found
alternative parking then the statement
cannot be true if no alternatives are
found then all of these vehicles will
put pressure on already overcrowded
street parking
so the parish council suggests that
additional parking could be provided by
all it at the end of George Street by
extending the existing parking bay which
is shown on the photograph here where
that dark car is parked we could
probably find space for another three or
four vehicles unfortunately our recent
experience in dealing with developers
when problems are caused by their
construction is not very encouraging
I'm sure orbit will be a more responsive
organization but the Parish Council
would feel much happier if strict
conditions are attached to the planning
permission that will deal with these two
issues thank you beyond the left-hand
side of the access road it's protecting
the access road that we're concerned
about good evening can you perhaps or
twice when you last carried out a
housing needs survey for Stockton that
was 2011 and what was the outcome of the
housing needs service survey did his
identity what sort of type of housing
did it identify there was a need for the
village well it identified both a mix of
open market housing and affordable
housing we think that a lot of the
affordable housing Lee that was
identified then has been met by the
subsequent Taylor Wimpey development of
77 houses they're providing about 24
affordable homes but I think if we did
in a recent a new housing needs survey
we'd still find a fair need for
affordable housing social housing it can
we have the ancient please which is mr.
Adams
we've got the three mr. Adams like a
warning shot with 30 seconds to go that
would be helpful thank you thank you
thank you I'm Jonathan Adams on the
director of Tatler King planning
consultants the proposal seek planning
permission for three two-bedroom
dwellings which will be providing
affordable rent this represents a
reduction from one unit from the
previously withdrawn scheme which was
before to bed rulings or batons as a
50-year history of providing affordable
homes throughout the country this
proposal represents an opportunity for
orbit to redeveloped an underused
Buckland garage size to provide family
housing for affordable rent as of today
only eight of the 24 garages are
currently leased and so it is reduced
from 10 and are on the basis of weekly
leases they could be terminated at any
time so this I cannot be relied upon to
deliver this and provide this parking
facility to close 16 characters are
vacant and are not available for new
tenants orbit all the areas with
residents nearest at the time of any
demolition to notify them of the time
scales involved despite it only be in
one weeks notice the affordable rental
properties sit within the local housing
allowance without being capped the
Stockton parish has any server which is
2013 are identified a need for
affordable homes for 30 local people but
as the parish council have said it is it
is they are still required the benefits
are provided three family sizes are
clear for the local area each will have
a private garden and two parking spaces
in line with the policy requirements the
parish council of stated their
objections account construction
management plan has been submitted with
the application to ensure
that's the retaining the what the the
bank will not collapse and that will
have to be agreed with the local
authority with regards to flood risk the
development will remove a substantial
area of hard standing that currently
exists by providing those gardens so
they the surface water runoff will
reduce and in any case there is a
condition regarding surface water the
remaining issues relate to highways as
we say as I have said the scheme the
site and a only eight the garages are
occupied and the site could be closed at
only one weeks notice 30 seconds I
respectfully ask you to consider the
significant material consideration which
is of substantial weight that the
professor will create three affordable
homes for local families who are need
who are in need of those are formal
affordable homes this outweighs the
parish councils concerns of our highways
which is not supported by the highways
officers or your officers Thank You mr.
Adam Scott on any questions for the
agent cancer 30 because the garages are
too dilapidated to repair the field and
can you just I'm not sure the relevance
of the question can you revise it please
well why are they taking them down
because they can't be used or is it I
thought it was obvious policy to do that
yes comment briefly for my answer orbit
remit is to deliver affordable homes
and this is an underused site 24 garages
and the eight are occupied and it is all
bits of you as his mayan only supported
by local plant policy and the MPP f to
make the most efficient you think you
don't very well that thank you here
right cancer simply yes chairman
could i ask if if they're only age
occupied is this because no new
tendencies are being granted or is that
the level of demand i'm told by the
applicant that that's the level of
demand people are not being forced to
leave the garages people are not
renewing the tenancies right any further
questions for agent Thank You mr. Adams
you're free to go
but haven't would a ward member that's
no so we go on to the points of
clarification and he questions to the
offices no I've got one point
clarification as part of the
construction management plan obviously
the price council concerned about the
stability of the bank how could that be
tackled as part of the construction plan
or is that an unreasonable condition
so that currently they've submitted a
draft construction management plan that
can only be in draft form at the moment
because contractor hasn't been assigned
to the site or gone through the the
procedure to get a contractor into sites
a certain matters can't be determined
until that that takes takes place
I think the fine the finer details and
we can condition a full construction
management plan through way through a
detail condition whether that's a
protective fencing or a barrier to the
site and from the previous application
we've realized how important parking is
in the local area so again the price
council race they should that there's a
possibility of three extra planning
sorry parking spaces in George Street
again potential thing that will falls
outside the application so it's I think
what what they've proposed is what's
before us tonight as the agent said any
point they can terminate the contract
for these 24 garages and the the parking
provision for these dwellings is
acceptable in its own right so you
basically sound that that's really
earthing and subject to negotiation
between orbit and the Parish Council
rather than it being relevant to this
application that's right obviously the
development can only consume its own
smoke and is providing the parking that
it needs to provide and therefore be
unreasonable to request further parking
elsewhere in the village just okay it's
the bonds if you actually move on to the
debate now okay so Perry thank you chair
I think as a district we need to be
welcoming affordable homes particularly
fordable homes for rent we have a
shortage it's a well thought out
application in my view providing
much-needed affordable homes and I would
move to the proposal
that we grant as a candle Thank You
chairman I completely agree with counts
Lipari it's well-designed the applicants
have taken reasonable steps to try and
meet some of the requirements the parish
council I think everything else is
covered in the paperwork I'm happy to
second the proposal okay we're going to
propose in the second counts the bonds
mr. Anders a lot of these garages are
left up empty because the people today
both put their car in the garage and
walk out so we've got them I think this
is a great game okay thank you for that
basically should we go to a vote all
those in favor of the officers
recommendation to grant 7 gem against
non-german abstentions 1 Chen right
committee resolves a grant application
18 / 0 3 1 0 for a few well
Cancer Center I think you might have to
fight Kate for this one we'll move on to
our next item on the agenda which is 18
/ 0 2 7 6 2 0 UT lund off rimmel close
Ruth head gender more closely bought on
star starless night at learnt
application for the erection of Dhamma
Bangla all martyrs Reserve Excel access
and Louise Casey is that presented
officer
Thank You chair so the application arm
for members is seeking out line planning
permission for the construction of a
single to touch dwelling with all
matters reserved
except for access so the application
site is identified here by the black dot
it's situated within the village of
Newbold
onto star so the application site is
outlined here in red the site is located
to the rear of the neighboring dwelling
hedge end and the grade 2 listed church
of Saint David is situated south east of
the site so you've got an aerial view of
the site just to demonstrate the
relationship between the properties
within the nearby vicinity application
site outlined here in red and Weavin are
now to the indicative site plan so we've
got the post indicative site plan and
access is proposed to the north east
corner of the site just here are three
more close so turning to the photos we
got the first image here looking towards
the site from rimmel close we've got the
site here and the second image panning
slightly to the left so you've got the
gable end of the neighbor and property
number a trim or close here and this is
views towards a site from within real
close to the south so site is behind
this tree just here and this photos
taken from within the site boundary so
facing towards the southwest and this
photos looking towards the rear
elevation of hedge end here final first
here's taken from the junction of real
close and moss lane to the north of the
site so the site situate just here
access will be run about here so please
leave the update sheet for an additional
neighbor comment which was received
after the officer report was written up
and chairman it's recommended to grant
the application for the reasons set out
in the report which could be fate found
on page 51 of the agenda move on to our
first speaker which is Natasha dissolver
they offset that correctly Natasha just
over
Thank You Natasha you've got three
minutes would you like about it
super good evening I am here to speak on
behalf of my client in support of this
outline application for a dorm a
bungalow
I thank officers for their constructive
feedback and assistance to date and
fully endorse their positive
recommendation as this is an outline
application the design details of the
dwelling are not under consideration
however it is proposed that the dwelling
will be a dormer bungalow which is in
keeping with the immediate surrounding
built form and is intended for use by
the applicant who is newly retired and
wishes to downsize a similar scheme was
approved on the site in 2002 but was not
implemented the site plan illustrates
the bungalows indicative location within
the plot as you can see right here the
plot has been separated from the
adjoining hedge end for over two years
both the existing and proposed dwellings
will have adequate external private
amenity space in terms of access as the
only matter not reserved via access onto
rim or closed is proposed and sufficient
parking provision and turning space will
provided on site to enable vehicles to
enter an egress the site in a forward
gear the Highways Authority has not
objected to the scheme and the case
officer has agreed that the proposal
will not be detrimental to highway
safety the ward member has ejected to
the dwelling on concerns related to the
quota of new dwellings in the village
already being met and that the proposed
dwelling has not been identified as
local needs by the parish council as new
bolt-ons tower is a category 3 local
service village it is deemed a
sustainable location for residential
development although new board has met
its quota for new housing small windfall
sites like this one are considered
acceptable and therefore the presumption
in favor does apply under policy CS 15
small scale schemes on suitable infill
sites within the built-up area boundary
are acceptable in principle and this
proposal is for a single dwelling on a
site that is clearly an infill part
within the boo AB
additionally as the scheme is compliant
with policy and located within a local
service village it is not necessary for
it to be identified as local needs by
the parish council I would like to know
that the Parish Council have not
actually objected to the scheme I should
also mention that proposal is similar to
a scheme approved in November on an info
plot across the road the Waldman that
did not object the scheme the scheme is
policy compliant and is a perfect
example of residential development on an
infill plot within a boo app the officer
has suggested a number of conditions be
attached to the decision notice which we
happily accept we hope that this is a
straightforward decision to approve the
scheme in line with the officers
recommendation and trust that members
will agree I am happy to answer any
questions you may have thank you thank
you very much any questions the bond is
the bond now in keeping with the other
properties yes it's a it's a dorm a
bungalow and the property next door
hedge end which is to the side is also a
dormer bungalow yeah so it's not bigger
than the surrounding once you've heard
the questions alright thank you you're
free to go
come we have our next speaker which is
the ward member catch the same place
yes Thank You chairman III have to
observe at the start I was taken to task
by the previous speaker on the reasons
for for my objection which they still
sustained right on the grounds that
newborn star has had its category which
she concedes and therefore windfall
sites don't necessarily form an
automatic right in my view to be granted
planning permission and there are
special reasons why I've objected to
this but didn't object to the site round
the corner across the road so to speak
which is clearly marked on the map on
page 61 of the agenda paper where there
is a huge gap now what concerns me
slightly is that the papers before us
tonight put an outline which is hard up
against the property known as edge end
yet we've just been shown examples of
the gifts as a gap and we were showing
photograph of a fence which effectively
separated that so therefore the
paperwork that's been people for book
before the committee might be deemed to
be slightly inaccurate however what I
have to look at is the nature of Rimel
clothes compared to most Lane and that
is this what Louise mentioned was the
great sue listed Church what she didn't
mention which is significant to my
argument is the nearby school which is
closer to this proposal than is the
church itself I don't think it has any
negative impact on the church if this
proposal was granted but and also the
issue comes from rhyme or close itself
now rhyme will close is a cluster of
eight elderly people's accommodation
with no garage and no parking whatsoever
that makes a significant difference
because in this day and age residents of
those sort of accommodation might well
at one stage when they were first built
be expected not to have cars but now
they do and where did they Park them
they parked them in the small lane which
confronts this access point as has been
described and is between the new
dwelling and the school and also the
score service is not just people in new
Bowl but children in treading sin as
well because that's the way it's
organized and therefore every morning
and every afternoon and as a massive
great coach turns up to take the
treading sand children back to
Chivington and get them there in the
first place therefore we have a
situation whereby there is a risk and a
confrontation of traffic congestion here
and bearing in mind that effectively
that I take the point that the applicant
we may wish to downsize that's that's
okay that's a question for them to
decide but whether they do it on this
sort of proposal I have huge doubts for
the simple reason that Ryan will close
doesn't have the space to deal with all
the parking plus an access for a new
dwelling plus the coaches that come to
take children to and from school twice a
day and therefore you've got a
potentially dangerous situation there
therefore whatever happened in 2002 I
don't recall I was war member then but I
don't recall it indeed as to what the
situation was but but but this is the
basic issue we had a traffic problem in
the making in Rome or close itself
adjacent to the pedestrian access to the
school
adjacent to the garishness houses in
Rimel close which require parking spaces
and probably Park in that road
itself and therefore conflict with the
access that's proposed that's been
described by Moody's this evening so
consequently I remain opposed to this
proposal and to compare it with my views
on on the proposals for loyalty round
the corner was more than slightly
operative opportunistic because it's a
completely different situation and
you're gonna tell me over 30 seconds am
i well I have more or less finished mr.
chairman because all I could do is
summarize the point but I have made it
it's a traffic issue in that area that
is the nature of my concerns and I think
it's a very real one right he's in a 30
mile an hour limit and I hope that
counts the brain won't try and tell me
I've got that wrong like he did earlier
tonight when I got it right but the
situation is this there's been to be a
lot of moving of traffic in a very
delicate and awkward situation no no I
think we'll move on
any questions for the ward member
councillor st. can I just check with
regards to the coach is coming and
interning for the school are they
specifically turning in the location
where the application is how is that
going to impact on the actual
application site with the coaches coming
in to drop off and pick up I'm not
certain do exactly where they pick up I
know they hold us up getting backing
into Moss Lane off the main a three 400
Road because I've been there in the
morning and the afternoon crucial points
in time and effectively but what I would
say to you is this just use your
imagination a little because you've got
five and six-year-olds because it's the
infant section of
join school the juniors isn't Reddington
buildings so therefore it's a split side
school between the two villages and what
happens is that you have got pretend
you've got a five and six-year-olds
going to be walking out of school onto
the bus wherever it goes or wherever it
parks and it's going to be stuck down
there and I think that creates a very a
very real problem thank you and you
further questions against the st. you're
free to go thank you my concern
clarification for the officers now okay
so don't go to [ __ ] where is the school
in relation to the application site I
wasn't clear so I'll take you to the
Google Earth you the school is situated
just here yes
guess what I told on is that Christian
it was the entrance that we're talking
about he's not opposite the school no no
in the score is only for little children
so just to clarify the accesses opposite
the school school situated here access
is going to be here access narrows at
all
it's not you counselor folding in the
pictures
I stand to be corrected by councillor
st. in his local knowledge here it
appears to me that the main entrance the
skooled is there from the north and that
there may be a pedestrian access
somewhere on right more close now I'll
happily correct Richard Gardner there
the main pedestrian entrance to the
school is round the corner in Rome will
close itself not a cross towards the
village green as he's pointed out I
think you'll find that that's an access
to houses that are in that area and the
school I think though is correctly
identified where the school was when she
was asked the question and unstated that
the entrance is opposite the pedestrian
entrance and exit to the school it's a
sight oh you're free to go again now and
could have the agent back as well just
for their view as well please on that
matter so could you just repeat the
question
we're concerned about the access to the
school as well where the access is the
pedestrian access yes there is a
pedestrian access on room or close I'm
told by my client that it's not the main
one there isn't another one on the other
side bearing in mind that it is young
children you might find that parents
tend to use the vehicle access which is
on the other side rather than that one I
would also like to point out there is an
existing vehicle access from our site
which can be used at the moment so it
wouldn't affect anything because they're
on the path on the other side of cars on
the other side of the road rather than
directly crossing our site okay thank
you
there's a pedestrian gate there but the
vehicle er one is round here to the
north sorry
the application sites there right thank
you I think you've clarified that um
I've got one point of clarification
though he's mentioned about being right
next the boundary there no one compared
to the next house I didn't quite catch
the question so if you look at the plan
which was provided in the agenda the
redline plan here is actually incorrect
it should actually be further south the
the fence line here shown on this place
the correct line where where the fence
is drawn between hedge end and the
application site but in the agenda this
plan provided here the red line is
actually in an incorrect position it
should have been further south and he
filled him is there a turning head at
the end of the lane where the cars can
come down turn around and go back again
and secondly how many other properties
feed into that Lane from their garages
how many other properties have access
onto the lane from that property so it's
these bungalows here so this is this
eight bungalow situated on on the close
I believe so yes thank you should we
move on to the debate then I think we've
clarified all the points against the
bonds then ok so Brian well I know this
item I don't really have a problem with
its in the respect that the bush usually
turns off the a3 400 back to little way
towards the school knock down that
particular road as far as I know they're
sort of five to seven-year-olds and then
they have to go on to present in I
always have concern when somebody wants
to build one house because under the
core strategy we can allow one house so
the situation is him my two of my
abilities I've got a replacement
dwelling and what do they want they want
to asses any planet and we can't stop
them so I'm afraid the numbers a bit of
a guide I think is the probably world
the last inspector said so I happy to
propose the application look at the
application on its merits not on the
councilors presented his objection
I followed Peter Barnes on this
councilor bond I think if there have
been any real words from the school or
the candy council Education Department
we would have seen it in the papers the
parish council bring no objections there
is one letter of objection I understand
that though I see no reason why
shouldn't support cancer bars and second
these proposals mr. Kenton I have
nothing further to add I agree with
what's been said mr Fielding basically
the same okay we'll move on then shall
we should we go to the vote I don't
believe we've got a proposal from cancer
brain and it was okay sir Barnes then
against the brain was seconded to
approve the application all those in
favor
unanimous chairman committee was officer
grant application 18 slices road to
seven
that's AMT and we'll move on to the
final item of the agenda and we'll just
wait for kicks the same to city's going
to vacate the for some reason I don't
know why he's actually vacated I don't
want to be a kid Jim the breaches of the
consular code of conduct again very much
right and I understand that I'm not even
allowed to be in the room where my
application is being discussed chairman
I've got to apologize in that I'm an
orbit tenant and I suppose though that I
should have let you know that before the
one in Stockton you abstained anyway so
this is not it's not yeah so you're not
problem at all worked yeah yeah if you
could only have any orbit applications
could you - could you declare Naaman
future through every more orbit
applications
right right when they move on to our
file application with me which is 1803
to SEMO ful Jasmine cottage trading
townships master resubmission of 1806 if
you are etc pres Louise Thank You
chairman so the application hour for
members is for the proposed partial
rebuild of the brick annex which is
situated to the rear of Jasmine cottage
the application site is out identified
here by the black dot and it's situated
within the village of trading turn it
also falls within the village
Conservation Area so the application is
a resubmission of the previously
approved eighteen / 0 0 7 double six
such ful the proposal remains largely
unchanged apart from a newly proposed
chimney stack stack to be sited within
the same position as the existing
chimney which you'll see in the photos
later on the previous permission granted
consent to replace the existing chimney
start with a 2 metre tall steel flue
however given issues surrounding the
support and stability of the structure
the current proposal is now seeking to
amend this aspect of the development so
the application site is outlined here in
red Jasmine cottage is a two-story brick
built cottage surrounded by neighboring
twins and all sides and the adjoining
neighbor and property charter school
house is great to list it so we've got a
Google Earth image here which
demonstrates the relationship between
the application site in the surrounding
dwellings and here we've got an existing
plan and elevation of the annex to the
rear of the site next up we've got the
proposed plan so the rebuild would be on
the same footprint as the existing with
the same form height and volume and the
existing brickwork and sites would be
reused so moving on to images the site
this is just looking forward looking
towards the front elevation of Jasmine
cottage second image is from the road
side to the east over the garden of
charity schoolhouse of the application
site if the
well in just here screen by at all
Britain and final images looking towards
the southeast elevation so this is the
annex with the chimney and we've got the
neighbor a mead cottage behind so it's
Justin cotton associated on X so there's
no updates chairman and it's recommended
to grant the application for the reason
set out in the report which can be found
on page 63 of the agenda speakers on
this item any points of clarification
before move is that way right it's being
recorded right catch the brain i'ma show
you got something accessible
presentations this word oddly the
officers delegated decision because it's
for a ground the only reason it is cost
the applicant is kind of sank so I
propose we go to the recommendation to
approve the recommendation which is for
ground from cats the cat the second it
all those in favor
hey you know they miss him
community resolves grant application
1803 two-seven-zero ful and we have no
items of urgent business or declare the
meetings closed
[Music]